[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today dylan is with us in boston
hi dylan welcome to the ramsay show
hi what a pleasure how are you better
than i deserve how can we help
so i am looking for some advice today um
i am about 55 000 in debt um 30k is in
student loans 18 is my car loan and i
have a 5 000 personal loan i took out
for a lower interest rate um for my
credit cards now i'm pretty new to your
baby steps program i'm just getting up
to speed and everything um i also have a
hundred thousand of parent plus loans in
my mom's name
um that she signed for for my
undergraduate at the time and i'm
looking for a plan to attack it uh she
doesn't make that much he makes around
30 000 a year and um i just started a
new job making 120 000 a year you're
single
yes
okay
all right so what you're telling me is
um you feel
for
one reason or another either by
agreement with your mom
or just by the fact that she can't deal
with it you feel obligated to pay the
parent plus loans
not legally but somehow morally or
ethically
yes have you all talked about this
um from time and time again um
i want to say every few months because
um it's been um delayed um with the
kovid
um and i know the payments are going to
start up soon with the interests um so
i'm trying to get into a conversation
with her about it on our plan for it
that's a lot of dancing around the
question have you all sat down and said
i would like to take these parent plus
loans and so when they kick back up i'm
gonna take the payment over
so i guess not seriously no okay all
right
i'll have that conversation
that's an important important
conversation so your mom is single and
makes thirty thousand dollars a year
uh my mom's married um
and so her and my dad make probably
around 120. i'm not sure the exact
number i know it's over 100.
okay why is your mom part of this
discussion and not your dad
um he didn't sign on any of the loans it
was just her it was just her and me at
the time
and now you didn't sign them their
parent plus loans
yes so your mother with or without your
father's knowledge took out a hundred
thousand dollars to send her son to
college
that's correct parents do that and
generally pay it back
i don't know why your mom is saddled
with this
they have some kind of fractured
relationship is your dad choosing to not
help her
um
yes
okay um so all right so i think we're a
little confused here so my dad is in the
pressure is my stepfather
okay
hopefully she's married too okay but
he's not helping her with her debts
she said this is your debt that you deal
with
okay yes
all right well if you're going to take
it on it simply goes in your debt
snowball
and if you're going to sit down with the
two of them and have a conversation that
says
um i make good money i don't want to
deal with this but i don't see how
you're going to be able to deal with
this i see it sinking you and so i'm
going to take the responsibility for it
mathematically you cannot take the legal
responsibility for it it's not legally
ever going to be yours
okay
but you can just pay it so you can start
paying the payments make it part of your
budget and then you do your debt
snowball and you list your debts
smallest to largest which means the last
debt you're going to get to are these
parent plus loans which is really what
it should be
um and uh uh
you know uh
i throw one important caveat in here
get the payment information and you pay
the loan service or directly oh yeah
yeah you're not gonna pay her you're not
giving her any money you're just taking
over the loan right you get the payment
book or or the payment uh password to
the website whatever it is and you're
going to make the payments you're going
to set it all up and then when you get
down to it you're going to pay extra on
it and get it done you're going to pay
it last for
three reasons one is it is not your debt
two is it's your largest debt once you
morally take it on so it's at the bottom
of your debt snowball
three is if god forbid she should pass
away the debt is forgiven
right and you would not she would not
owe it anymore
okay now i have a follow-up question
um
now what is your confidence level in uh
student loan forgiveness zero um
zero okay
i know we're in an income driven you can
tell politicians are lying when their
mouth is moving
i like that here's the problem dylan the
problem with the student loan
forgiveness is they haven't shut off the
spigot yet if they continue to make
student loans it's intellectually
dishonest to discuss stock
to discuss forgiving the ones that are
already in place while they're
continuing to make them so every student
when they quit making them yeah then we
can start having a discussion that it
might be happening that they're going to
forgive them but if they but they're not
even those people up there the island of
misfit toys called congress even those
guys are not so dumb that they're going
to forgive
willy-nilly all these loans everywhere
and then turn around and keep making
them and put everybody right back in and
then fall semester rolls around and
everyone's right back in here we go
let's go again
here we go everybody get in line get up
to the trough you piggies
you know no it's not that's not that
even they are not that stupid so no you
just got 120 000
60 000 bucks going into 155 so you got
three years two and a half years of
beans and rice rice and beans and you
can clear every bit of this but you have
no life during the next two and a half
to three years
no inside you you know so if you go on a
date it's going to be a with a frisbee
at the park
i mean it's not going to be
you got you got nothing dude you're
going to dig up this mess if you're
taking his son if you're taking this on
then you got to take it on you got to
treat it like you know
good the good news is you make 120 000
as a young guy yeah you know and so you
got a good size shovel and you can just
tear your butt into this thing and
that's what you're going to have to do
you can knock out your debts pretty
quick and then you're gonna hit the wall
called mom's debts